hey so you happy this it seems like
happiness I don't know what's in a
hurricane I'm from Cleveland Ohio and we
don't have hurricanes there either
people don't know what this is every
time I mention it or they look like they
have severe flashbacks of a horrible
experience with this drink which makes
me super excited to be drinking this
when I see this drink I definitely think
like Freddy got New Orleans it smells
like what you drink when you're like in
your first year in college yeah and
you're like give me whatever yeah this
is that night where you like call up two
ex boyfriends or girlfriends that you
should adios adios this tastes like
Mardi Gras it's like a strawberry
shortcake made an alcohol she'd make
this the first stage is like sweet and
then like the alcohol punch comes in
that's a dangerous oh it's good though
it's like oh I feel like I'm in Cabo if
I can't even touch it
it's like Kanye
I would love another of course Kenny had
two she's such a lush he and I feel
closer to you
Brianna is so cute I feel it like when
my hobbies to feel it you got it yeah
what are you gonna dance with me over
yourself I could do to be when I'm sober
but I could see it's with you like on it
like break it down like a PA I just I
feel like my I feel fidgety cuz I want
to dance and only from this that's
amazing
if only the weather phenomenon was this
delicious and not nearly as devastating
cheers New Orlean Tea Room beautiful
yeah you're beautiful keep up the good
work you're getting making people across
the globe happy every day
good job girl good job girl
don't I love you